okay to go okay thank you
so this money is our first meeting Klaus
thank you man and I'll propose myself as
vice-chair our second man to Ryan from
inside as a chair as a vice chair thank
you so okay thank you for be over I
think before I kick off I just want to
say that we'll run this as usual I know
it's a zoom meeting which is a little
bit extraordinary I suppose for us where
we usually meet in person
you probably got usage by now people
want to speak if we could press the hand
up button or raise your hand on the
participants list so I've got your name
on there come back Oh any points we'll
go through the agenda which y'all should
have the papers for and I suppose as a
as a starter for ten I'd like to thank
that the outgoing chair flash beans per
year Molly from Rochdale for his
fantastic tarnished chair and the
building of stars we've seen across the
last year and two the rain and the whole
team for the work that they've put in
over the past year and especially
through this really difficult time
during kovat to manage to keep the
authorization and functioning really see
some of that I suppose as we consider
some of these papers through so thank
you both for your time
over this year and I hope that I can you
know fill those shoes you move forward
with council McGee from Stockport so
thank you very much okay so in terms of
attending this fabiola where are we
Quorra tan okay
attendance gender item one yes we are
Church
thank you the minutes item two minutes
of the previous meeting
people have to agree okay everybody with
that thank you thank you everyone any
declarations of interest no I'm seeing
shaking heads nobody come through if
you'd let us know in the usual way if
you have to after this let us know as
well item four so the cost to progress
report who's taking us through that yeah
this is one of the items coming forwards
from the December meeting so we just
need to have a motion to move this right
so are we okay to move that happen to
move that yes thank you everyone
Kovac update to item five that's myself
chattering thank you the rain if you
want to take us through Thanks any
questions or anything through if you
could just raise your hand on the
participants list and I'll keep an eye
on it so we can keep a little list okay
nice to see you on the screen this
afternoon and just to take you very
quickly through the coated paper what we
felt was helpful for joint committee
this afternoon was to bring you up to
date really of activity in a summarized
form of what we've been doing on your
behalf over the last three months and I
won't go into great detail because
you've read the paper you've been with
us along the journey of the last three
months through the crisis so I just take
you to a sort of highlights and really
how we've approached this and more
importantly how we're actually going to
move and forwards as we hopefully come
out of lockdown and move into recovery
and I just danced at my notes if I may
basically where our advice and guidance
comes from as always tends to be
government-led central government and we
get things called PP ends which are
procurement policy notices and some of
you are very familiar with these terms
but basically what the government do
through through the LGA particularly and
cabinet offices the issue notices which
fight for more quite long and what we've
done is interpreted those obviously made
them star eyes in order that the fit of
purpose for your individual for councils
we've acted as a conduit really
particularly in the first few weeks to
make sure that we rapidly mobilized new
ways of working we've set up emergency
procedures because it's important that
we act quickly and we use things like
Regulation 432 within the regs to
mobilize procurement that needs to be
done immediately to help us deal with
the crisis I would say on the whole
that's that's happened very smoothly and
we feel that we move quite quickly after
a number of weeks into a settlement
period and we had very little activity
through emergency procedures which was
really good and we've continued to
maintain business as usual as we've
moved forwards and some of the
highlights really we've been contacted
nationally in particular from
organizations like Transport for London
and the Alzheimer Society who picked up
through various means about what what
star does in terms of its shared service
expertise but also looking at local
spend successes social value successes
so on the side of suppose we've been
offering advice and guidance to other
organisations which has been really good
to get start out there and into the
spotlight and I think the final thing to
add to this chair is we've produced
something called a 10-point plan which I
know you've all had a copy of it's gone
into every form of social media that we
can find and what we're currently doing
is we're building activities against
those ten points in order that over the
next two three four weeks we will start
a drip feed update so both yourselves as
joint committee members and board
members and key officers within your
councils know what progress were making
and what we're trying to do is target
local spend atthenes vsi's and be AME
organisations to try and look at how we
help the business communities and
obviously the economy as we move out of
lockdown and help to mobilise people
back into some shape of normality we
understand the pressure we understand
what you need from us in terms of
councils and your corporate priorities
and I'm sure they will change as we go
forwards but I'm happy to take any
questions chat thank you thank you very
much Lorraine it's quite a substantial
report I think we've looked at their
immediate things that you did at the
time and had look at different processes
from ways that we adapted to this
situation but again if I could just
reiterate my thanks really and I'm sure
the thanks of the whole committee in
continuation of the word that you've
done to make sure that we've been able
to keep on track and achieve things we
have achieve noticed in there on the
final section in point four James Hunter
council epic award so really to say
congratulations to him as well for his
leadership of PPE procurement and I feel
like law we say procurement is not
sometimes most interesting thing for a
lot of people actually it's some of the
most important conversations that you
can have in terms of crisis management
to make sure how you get things and how
you can continue to move on so thank you
very much any questions or comments or
anyone figure it okay I've got
councillor Ross Tom Russ and again thank
you so much to star for everything
you've done in these very unprecedented
that's a word times I just wanted to
check the welfare overall the the team
how they've been doing because that's do
they were all presumably having to move
out of them out of the office sites and
working from home and in terms of the
own recovery how are they at the moment
they keen to get back into the office
office and get back around the table as
it were what what's happening now with
the with the with the team max I know
it's been very difficult for a lot of
people having to adapt a new working
conditions and remember kind of mental
health perspective while it can be quite
challenging to for people so so any
update on that would be great thank you
yes go ahead
how's the Ross thank thank you for the
feedback and an update from yourself and
personally we're very used to large are
working the privilege of working across
four councils is we're used to having
laptops and sitting where we need to sit
and functioning so I would say we're
probably best placed it to show how this
can be done quickly and the team on
whole have been very buoyant and
resilient during the time and we've only
had one person with coded symptoms who
was actually quite poorly but she's fine
and back and working I would say from a
mental health point of view I think
we've had ups and downs right through
the team from from me downwards in terms
of you know child care challenges you
know trying to find a corner of a lounge
to sitting for some people which has
been quite difficult but on the whole
that you know
in a very resilient and we've got a lot
of support from traffic counselors our
host employer in terms of referring one
or two for some mental health guidance
really and different welfare issues I
think one colleague did a social
distance walk one-to-one with one member
of staff one day that we felt was quite
isolated living in a house on her own so
you know all in it together and we've
looked after each other so I think we've
got through it and we're all fine thank
you well thank you that's great that's
really good to hear any more questions
or comments on Lorraine's our plate Casa
McGee Thank You Jay and I to notice the
the
James from from Trafford as you say not
usually the sort of area that gets
recognition but I thought you were just
saying matter of life and death
because it literally in some cases it
has been but I would and I was
interested in the points on Ross made as
well about welfare well I I just wanted
to ask the emergency I guess there's two
points one is the emergency procurement
needs because back then you can't go
through the system the way would
normally be because when you need to get
something in place it's not things
happening or growing worse than you need
to do that is really good but I was also
interested in the development in the
sort of the charity not the profit
organization there must be there must be
a large market out there Thank You Wayne
yeah I caught the first question I'll
have to ask forum and feedback on the
second please councillor McGee but then
you have to respond to the first
question and we've obviously been at the
forefront of PPE procurement for our for
councils done indeed for Greater
Manchester and I will say that there's
been a number of businesses and one in
particular in Tyneside actually and that
has converted their whole business
operation of normally doing work we're
into doing and aprons and those sorts of
things that I would say we've worked
hard with businesses and we've tried to
push that local standard gender as best
we can through the crisis because it is
you can imagine we've been inundated
worldwide through every source I think
my linkedin has been pinging every three
minutes with
somebody offering me masks legitimately
or not and so we've probably had to look
at that from a safeguarding point of
view financially to make sure not buying
something that doesn't get delivered
because we've all heard those stories I
think in terms of the voluntary and
community sector we're very aware that
there's a massive risk here for those
sectors and indeed the small and medium
enterprises who are struggling and you
know who haven't already popped a very
vulnerable so for me it's about how we
use every rule that we can certainly
below the og threshold to really really
work hard to target spend and really get
back stand within Greater Manchester
over the next few months so I'm still
ambitious that I want to hit those
targets for you during this year and
actually you know move that local pound
forwards even further because it's
always been our agenda and key priority
but even more so to actually help those
communities to survive I think the third
point to make on that chair if I may is
we've worked hard on looking at what
other business entities need really over
the next few months and we've been
working hard with the LGA as well
because they seem to use star quite
often now as a bit of a voice box of
people who know what to do and do it in
a practical sensible and quick way so
that that's quite a privilege but
actually they put it in touch with
people like their somas society who are
saying we actually need to be shared
service and sharing services now we
actually need to function differently
now because actually we won't survive
unequally how can a big voluntary
organization help smaller voluntary
organisations tenses engaging with with
one of the directors from that
particular organisation so we're pushing
and I suppose the expertise out there
and but not taking our eye off the ball
in terms of delivering for for the staff
partners
what's there another part of the
question cuz oh yeah Thank You council
Magee any more comments questions from
members for Lorraine I can't see
anything
other than just to make a final comment
on the ten-point plan that we put
together and have publicized quite well
I would encourage people to have a look
at that and this is particularly I think
we've we've done really well trying to
communicate that message of what we're
doing during kovetz train adapts and
help where we can and I think it's
partly the raise in a report but
actually that was a really good piece of
work I think we probably all praise as
well so thank you very much for that
okay so to move on then are you on a
next report as well Lorraine I think it
moves to Nicola next okay just check my
list here with me course recourse for
yes that's me okay thank you hi and so
yeah I'm just going to go through the
Equestria and courts for performance
measures we're bringing them together in
one report because clearly we have to
cancel the March joint committee and
because for obvious reasons so I'm just
going to take you through that reports
but I am going to with the use of
technology share our new dashboard with
you so let me just see if that can
everyone see that on the screen now we
can I think if you just scroll down a
touch Nicola so we could just see the
bottom of it but no that's the magic of
digital technology working marvelous so
we've got this tableau dashboard that we
now use for our performance management
so I thought being show this to you
today so if we just starting with the
KPIs then on savings we had a target of
5.2 million pounds for the year we have
so far got just over 5 million ratified
and there is another one point nine
million waiting to be ratified but we've
struggled to get that completed GT
obviously resource pressures within the
finance teams in all all four partners
so we think that we will more than reach
our target once those same into ratifies
and actually nearly 7 million pounds
worth of savings generated this
financial year which is a fantastic
achievements that therefore means that
your return on investment your annual
investment is four point two times so
that that's showing that we're showing
good value for money there there's also
some additional non ratified savings
which is where we just to show
additional service that can't be taken
from budgets but we're procurement has
added value so
process so just moving on to income we
have a target of 150,000 and as you can
see with more than nearly doubled the
income for this year we 287 K just where
the day you've got the breakdown by
quarters and you can see that was we
brought is slightly less than what we
thought we were going to in quarter
three but that was the one piece of work
that's been delayed by GMC a but that
now he's been brought into this
financial year anyway so the income is
still coming in it's just being delayed
and then just take you to the social
value waiting just grow across a bit so
this shows we've had massively increased
our social value and by the end of
quarter four we were reporting about 20%
social evaluated on both above and below
oh gee and thresholds we'll see from the
report that obviously shows oh it's
twirling you can see the massive
increase this year and the the final
figure is the average over the year but
just shows the in courts for we were
actually delivering more than what the
target was further down as well the
contracts with social values so this is
where the number of contracts or the
percentage of contracts that have
actually got social value kpi's in them
and again that's massively increased and
we well above target for that as well
and then just finally we've had no legal
challenges this year 30 not had one
since star forms so fingers crossed that
will continue so is there any questions
on that Thank You Nicola I think that
will probably bring a bit of a heart
lift to all of our finance directors in
a time of difficulty that this is been a
you know really positive time for start
I can't see the participant list but if
anybody has their hand up if you could
let us know we have any comments or
questions
Tom McGee go ahead really good I thought
yeah easy to read so I'm guessing there
are a lot of our operations
life goes on therefore we we remain
happen to be a just certain contract
because of the code we'd but for a lot
of others it's just keeping going and
and that we need to then think about how
we yet how we perhaps some nudge things
in the right direction over the next 12
months yeah so one of the things we have
launched is the social value plug-in for
example so when organizations have
promised to social value and it might
have been through high school physics
for example which clear they're gonna
struggle to deliver now we're giving
them the option to change their social
value commitments and also anything to
do specifically around colvett as well
that they could use that as part of
their social value offer to us as well
so we are trying to be adaptable
may have implemented procedures to deal
with that changing prices so
particularly several at the beginning we
weren't sure about what the prices were
going to be in the construction industry
for example which should about supply so
we put some flexibility into our
procurements to allow allow them great
okay Thank You Nicola any more questions
or comments tom ross you and yeah that
all looks really really good and it
would be great to have pictures just
going off any an earlier conversation
we've had about social media i think
some of those graphics are quite
shareable via like twitter and facebook
and it might not be it gets a massive
audience of people out there who are
keen on procurement but it might hit the
right people to kind of grow star
further so anyway of could putting those
into into infographics that we could all
share
hopefully that would kind of a trap more
attention to star as well thank you very
much for that and obviously keep up the
good work
thank you I knew there was a word for it
infographics yeah
thank you both thumbs any more questions
or comments for Nicola yes yeah go ahead
those were the KPIs do are some reports
on performance measures which are
procurement worth measures which of
those where we don't have targets but we
think you'd be helpful to report them so
and they are all set out in the report
and a particular just wants to draw
attention to the social value ones
including quarter three and quarter four
boxes of course the four ones are more
relevant so we've now has 62 tenders
going through the social value portal
over half now have been awarded to
greater manchester suppliers and are
also seeing a 25 percent return on the
contract value with social value as well
so it's really showing the power of the
social value portal in the way that
we've been doing to me the social value
without particularly our local supply
chains we were responding really well to
that as well the other things to draw
your attention to is the number of SL
A's
so we've fulfilled a lot of essays which
is where all that income has come from
that includes DMCA the Greater
Manchester Health and Social Care
Partnership as well as now further
afield including monitoring the
pathology review force and well and
Birmingham Council's and a review of
puzzled and shared service as well so
we've been able to secure income and
secure income from outside Greater
Manchester as well which is really
positive we've also continued with
stakeholder training so we've had 37
different events with over 500 employees
and just picking up on the staff welfare
issues and things we've continued with
the staff training as well we've
actually had over 550 hours of CPD for
the star team of this last year so
that's really helping us to retain our
position as the employer of choice as
well and to keep our staff retention up
and we have we continue to
look at the social media as well and so
we have now been looking at updating our
websites and that will hopefully mean
that the number of website views and
then also the rest of our social media
will start to pick up as we move forward
excellent really excellent Thank You
Nicola any questions comments funicula
nope sorry sorry sorry so I think we've
done this before remember and the
quarter for Megan is about the number
tenders and all that and we could we
could not doctor we could use a press
release with all the information into
our local needs if you could put that
one together because I'm sure that thing
that locally want people understand
what's happening with the process would
become more interesting so you know
Rochdale ourselves as well as traffic
and change so I could all make use of
that in slightly different ways oh
absolutely absolutely agree that be
really helpful I think in the champion
section social media section we can see
there we are kind of doing more to
engage that people I think that's a
really good thing there's a few points
in there in the champions section make
life including yourself taking part and
the sector solutions Expo we are getting
out there and spreading the message and
I feel like this is a really positive
quarter and hopefully we'll be able to
see some more that progresses we
progressed through the year so thank you
very much no more questions or comments
for Nicola
no okay I think if we can move on then
to urgent business I've not been told
that we have any if anyone can advise
I've not been alerted to any urgent
business okay thank you very much
so the date and time of the next meeting
will be there is in front of you 16
September 2 p.m. this may be a virtual
meeting I think this is where it's out
well for people in terms of having a
virtual about how people feel but this
is quite a good forum for us to look at
perhaps even into the future post kovat
as part of the whole digitization of how
we do business
and if I could have members to stay back
and because there is a section that I
just need to ask you about whether we
can move to exclusion of the present
public to deal with the last few items
on this agenda are people comfortable
with that can people take that motion to
move that okay and seconded by
Councillor Ali thank you very much okay
so if we can end the recording that
that's great